here's the brooklyn borough president
who's currently the democratic nominee
for the new york city mayor and author
of the book healthy at last eric adams
is over here
thank you sir
eric how you doing quite well bill you
know
i really have a confession to make to
all
uh that all of this uh was a septifuge
i did all of this just so i could get on
this dawn show
man and i finally got here
i appreciate you saying that because i
was going to say to you right off the
bat i'm not going to be coy i'm a big
fan
i love what you're doing no i i mean
i i honestly i didn't know about you
until six months ago but then everything
i read now when people ask me about you
i'm like i love this [ __ ] guy
this is what the democratic party needs
so just you're going to be the mayor of
new york unless there's a zombie
apocalypse
uh just and you you know it's such a
great story
because you had a message that was
different from everybody else's message
and it proves that once in a while in
politics you can put a product
out there and the people will say ah i
didn't know about that but now that i
see it yes that's what we need
that's what we want so just quickly for
everybody who's just getting to know you
sum up that message that you had that
has taken you to this great victory
well really it's my life story you know
15 year old
i was arrested beat by police officers
and instead of saying what was me i said
why not me i went into the police
department
started an organization to fight for
safety and justice together
and i did that moved up through the
ranks became a captain
and i saw the impact of proper policing
but also they saw the impact
of the criminality in our cities across
america
and i pursue justice and safety and i'm
just an everyday
everyday person a dishwasher as a child
uh
lived on a verge of homelessness we used
to carry a garbage bag full of clothing
to school every day
because we thought when we come home we
would be thrown out went to school at
night
study i went through my entire
educational experience
experience in public school not knowing
i had a learning disability
until i stumbled on to it in college and
got the resources
and so people just felt the authentic
story
of how i want to turn around the city of
new york and inequality
and see our economy grow at the same
time
and you you said when you were running
you were not running just against
candidates you said i'm running against
a movement yes what did you mean by that
we see what's happening in in america we
see the demonization of
public safety which i believe is the
prerequisite to prosperity
we see the demonization of those who are
high income earners
uh 65 000 new yorkers pay 51
of our income taxes if we lose them we
lose the teacher the firefighter the
department of sanitation employee they
pay those taxes
uh that we need and we just see the
divide of our countries
and listen this is not a socialist
country let's be clear on that this is a
country
that believes to give people the
opportunities
and they will be able to exceed and
excel in this country and i believe in
that
is because that's what i saw on my
personal journey and the journey of so
many people who come to this country
[Applause]
it sounds like a long way of saying you
have common sense which
it seems a lot of times from my view
lacking in the democratic party would
you believe that that is their achilles
heel i mean you have said
that they better pay attention to what
you achieved in new york or they're
going to lose the midterm elections and
they're going to lose the next election
is this what you're talking about that
people look at the democrats and they
just see so many things that are goofy
because they
somehow think twitter is the electorate
and it's not
so true i could not have said it better
i i stated this
on the day of the primary uh people on
social media
uh don't decide these elections people
on social security
uh they decide these election everyday
people but bill you know what we're
doing in our country in cities across
america
uh archbishop doesn't mean two two
headed quote we spend a lifetime
pulling people out of the river no one
goes upstream
and prevent them from falling in in the
first place we
let people falling in a river of crime
forced to care children not getting
support
homelessness health just think about
health
you know my story lost my sight with
type 2 diabetes
permanent nerve damage had an ulcer high
blood pressure high cholesterol
because i was feeding my crises based on
what i was eating every day
i changed my diet in three weeks my
vision came back three months my
diabetes went in remission
my nerve damage went away it was never
my
dna it was my don dinner i was feeding
my
health care crisis and we do that every
day in america
i want to go upstream and prevent people
from falling in a river of despair
you